el acuario cilíndrico más grande del
mundo ha colapsado el aquadum ubicado en
un hotel de lujo de Berlín explotó
derramando un millón de litros de agua
salada y dejando alrededor de 1.500
peces exóticos muertos dos personas
heridas levemente y a más de 35
atendidas por cuerpos médicos además de
daños graves en la infraestructura
cercanas al hotel
sonaba casi como fuegos artificiales
pero el hotel en realidad tembló por
dentro podría describirlo como un
salte de la cama y me di la vuelta
él casi centenar de especies tropicales
que contenía el acuario fue expulsada a
las calles cercanas muchas de ellas
fueron arrastradas a las alcantarillas
de la ciudad mientras que algunas
lograron ser rescatadas y llevadas a
otros acuarios causando indignación
social ante la emergencia unas 3.500
personas fueron evacuadas del complejo y
se les dio refugio en autobuses ya Que
las temperaturas exteriores rondaban los
siete grados centígrados bajo cero el
acuado mera una estructura de 25 metros
de altura que fue inaugurada el 2 de
diciembre de 2003 y permitía a los
huéspedes del Hotel ver los peces desde
las habitaciones y desde un ascensor que
atravesaba el tanque para la firma
constructora era imposible que algo así
ocurriera
en lo que respecta a la destrucción o el
vandalismo se podría hacer un pequeño
agujero con armas pequeñas o algo así
por donde podría salir un poco de agua
pero no reventar todo el cilindro estos
escenarios de Hollywood o los peores
escenarios no podrían tener lugar aquí
la alcaldesa de Berlín dijo que gracias
a que el incidente ocurrió en la
madrugada los daños humanos no fueron
mayores e Indicó que el cuerpo de
bomberos realiza inspecciones para
esclarecer las causas del siniestro